tous ces moments où on se questionne
quoi puisqu'il joue là qu'est ce qui m'a
pris ce que moment où tu galères en
anglais tu sais même pas dire comment tu
veux une baguette
enfin fait et ce que tu la trouves déjà
la baguette là bas je devais avoir pas
loin de 6 ans quand j'ai rencontré
djamel on était très très jeune puisque
on a grandi dans le même quartier j'ai
l'impression en fait qu'il a toujours
été dans mon environnement finalement on
a grandi ensemble gta même classe que
son petit frère et on a évolué grandi
ensemble
je me souviens de la fois où il a fait
ou notre rapport il a changé en fait
c'est que c'est cette fois là en fait
tout comme comme souvent il y avait un
match de foot organisé dans le quartier
est bon en équipe était dehors puisque
je n'étais pas très fort au foot
jamais ni vous le dira pas mais c'était
un peu son cas même si lui pense qu'ils
jouent et bien et donc on après on
discute on tchatche ont fait un peu on
fait un peu les comptes et lui à
l'époque il est déjà un peu loin est
fait il passe du temps à trappes dont il
est déjà comme on dit il va souvent à
paris et à ce moment-là il m'entend
déconner et je pense qu'ils découvrent
ce truc-là de moi qui l'avais pas parce
que il me connaît mais connaît comme un
petit comme ça et là il découvre ça de
moi et puis et puis et puis là on se met
à se marrer ensemble et puis c'est la
une propose de venir le rejoindre un
ovale quelques jours plus tard
[Musique]
c'était le moment tu dois t'adapter
j'aime bien moi ces moments là où c'est
un peu l'aventuré on doit s'adapter ou
faut se renouveler en fait le confort ça
y est il est plus là il faut europe faut
se réinstaller je me suis construit un
peu là dedans dans un truc un peu
inconfortable d'être à l'ailé ça m'a
permis ça en fait de devoir me
représenter dire mon prénom c'était
quelque chose d'important pour moi et
que c'était bien d'avoir à vivre ça il
ya toute une histoire derrière par
rapport à ce film c'est à dire que eric
ollivier quand ils me proposent ils me
le disent vraiment comme ça ils me
disent on va on va te on va trouver un
film pour pour que tu comprennes que tu
as un acteur moment on me dit on donne
mon nom ben je pense à ça ils sont juste
derrière moi quoi et donc forcément il
ya quelque chose qui monte en moi
quelque chose à ada c'est dingue
et puis je regarde ma femme qui est
juste à côté je vois bien dans ses yeux
il se passe un truc fou et je comprends
en fait que ben est que l'ajustement là
je le comprends qu'il ya une espèce de
basculer en train de se faire et je
comprends qu'il va y avoir un avant et
un après à ce moment là je ne sais pas
quoi précisément mais je comprends bien
quelque chose qui est en train de se
faire qu en train de caen train de
bouger
une page qui se tourne c'est très très
fort à ce moment là ça serait prêt force
est très précis encore ce cet instant où
je les sens présent et que tout ce
voyage qui se fait de passer du passé à
l'avenir et autres que métaphysique fou
mais je repense à ce truc là est d'une
taille n'ont fait jusqu'au bout quoi le
césar du meilleur acteur il en vrai bon
fait donc je les remercie encore pour
satire j'en profite